hi it's Michele from lab life and beauty
science chemistry PhD skincare nerd and
pigmentation monster my skin loves
producing pigment and I live in sunny
Australia
so obviously sun protection is one of my
big obsessions a good sunscreen is one
of the most important things you can use
to prevent pigmentation so things like
sunspots and to help you fade acne marks
to understand sunscreen you need to know
about UVA and so that's the topic of
today's video if you like this sort of
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
my channel and make sure you hit the
notification button so that you don't
miss out on any videos so first up what
is UVA the Sun emits 3 main types of
light there's UV which is ultraviolet
there's visible light which we can see
and there's infrared or IR I've talked
about what visible light can do to your
skin in a previous video and today we're
going to be focusing on the Big Kahuna
which is UV UV light is divided into 3
major types this is according to how
much energy they have which is inversely
proportional to their wavelength in
other words the shorter the wavelength
the higher the energy the shortest
wavelength highest energy light is UVC
this has wavelengths of 100 to 280
nanometers since it's the most energetic
it's the most harmful luckily it's also
the least penetrating it's almost
completely blocked by the atmosphere and
the ozone layer so you don't really need
to worry too much about it the next type
is UVB which is from 280 nanometers to
350 nanometers this is probably the type
of UV you've heard about the most about
90% of the UVB that the Sun produces
gets absorbed by the ozone layer which
is 25 kilometers above the Earth's
surface this means that for Australians
and other people who live close to the
South Pole it's a bigger issue because
there's an ozone hole above Antarctica
which means that it lets in more UV
light we also have really nice sunny
weather which means
were more likely to be outside uvv cause
the sunburns and skin cancer but luckily
it is mostly blocked by glass it's also
at the type of UV from the Sun that's
involved in vitamin D production UVB is
the strongest in summer and in the
middle of the day it's mostly what's
measured by the UV index which you can
look up on your local weather site
finally we have UVA which is from about
350 to 400 nanometers this is the lowest
energy since it has the longest
wavelength out of the different types of
UV light it has slightly shorter
wavelengths than visible light UVA
penetrates the atmosphere better it's
about 95 percent of the UV that reaches
the Earth's surface and it also
penetrates deeper into your skin than
UVB the main impact of UVA on your skin
is that it forms highly reactive free
radicals in your skin which have
unpaired electrons this means that
they're really good at reacting with
whatever's around like your DNA
UVA causes wrinkles and sun damage in
your skin as well as deadly melanomas
it's the type of UV that you'll find in
tanning beds and in black lights like
with UVB UVA levels depend on the time
of day and the time of year but compared
to UVB it varies a lot less that means
it's important to think about UVA
protection even during off-peak times as
well UVA is further subdivided into uva
1 and uva true uva 1 has longer
wavelengths so it's above 340 nanometers
uva chu has shorter wavelengths it's
closer to UVB and it's below 340
nanometers the main reason that UVA is
less famous than UVB is that the dangers
of UVA weren't really known until
relatively recently UVA effects are also
less immediate and they build up over
time which means that it's sort of more
dangerous UVA z' ability to penetrate
deeper than UVB is also quite scary so
can penetrate through glass like the
glass in your car side windows which is
why there's lots of asymmetric skin
cancers emerging as well as asymmetric
wrinkle patterns so for example there's
a famous photo of a truck driver he
drove a truck with the windows closed
for about 28 years
the left side of his face received
direct Sun the right side received in
direct Sun and you can see the massive
difference in wrinkles even if you never
go to the beach and you never sunbathe
you can still be affected by UVA it's
been estimated that about 80% of UVA
damage actually comes from everyday life
so things like if you're walking around
if you're driving or even if you're
sitting near a window now let's talk
about sunscreen sunscreens almost always
have an SPF rating SPF stands for Sun
Protection factor and the higher the SPF
the higher the protection you have
against erythema UV in other words UV
that causes your skin to burn SPF mostly
measures protection against UVB although
shorter wavelengths of UVA will also
cause burning about 9 to 20% of the
reaction if you have a sunscreen that
only blocks against UVB you can actually
only get an SPF of 11 so there is UVA
protection shown in the SPF the concept
of SPF was introduced in 1970 before all
of this UVA research and so back then
scientists assumed that the only damage
you could get to your skin was sunburn
and so that's what we protected
ourselves against using sunscreens I've
talked more about SPF and whether or not
higher SPFs are better in a different
video which I've linked below the
problem with SPF is that it doesn't
really tell us that much about
protection against longer wavelengths of
UV especially that UVA one because we
now know that UVA is also dangerous a
lot of countries have introduced other
regulated terms in sunscreens that
describe how much UVA protection you're
getting the most popular term is
something called broad-spectrum there
are a few slightly different ways of
measuring it the first method is using
something called critical wavelength the
ability of the sunscreen to absorb UV is
measured over different wavelengths and
for a sunscreen should be classified a
sports spectrum under this critical
wavelength criteria 90% of the total
area under the absorption curve from 290
to 400 nanometers needs to be higher or
equal to 317 nanometers the other
criteria that sometimes used for
broad-spectrum
is that the UVA protection factor has to
be at least one third of the labeled SPF
in Australia in the EU both of these
have to happen before a sunscreen gets
the broad-spectrum rating in the u.s.
broad-spectrum sunscreen only need the
critical wavelength criteria what this
means is that in general a higher SPF is
going to give you better UVA protection
Australian and EU sunscreens also give
you better guaranteed protection than a
u.s. sunscreen that's because critical
wavelength does tell you about how wide
the protection is so the broad spectrum
but it doesn't tell you that much info
about how much protection you're getting
so in other words how strong that
protection is one recent study did find
that US sunscreens give less protection
then the sunscreens that require both
critical wavelengths and the one third
SPF rule out of the 20 sunscreens tested
in this study 19 of them passed the US
test but only 11 of them passed the EU
regulations with the extra 1/3 SPF
requirement in some other countries
there's more specific UVA protection
ratings
there's the PPD rating which stands for
persistent pigment darkening this
measures how well a sunscreen protects
you against a long-term tan that's
caused by UVA it's basically the
equivalent of SPF but for UVA you'll
often find PPD ratings in European
sunscreens there's also the PA rating
this is pretty similar to PPD but it
uses plus signs and it's more popular in
Asian countries pa+
roughly translates to PPD 2 to 4p a
double plus is PPD four to eight P a
triple plus is PPG eight to sixteen and
P a quadruple plus is PPD 16 and above
unfortunately P a ratings don't tell you
how far above PPD 16 a sunscreen might
be
[Music]
another way of checking if you're
getting good UVA protection is by
looking at the actual sunscreen
ingredients most sunscreen ingredients
don't give great protection against
longer wavelength UVA one these curves
show you the protection ranges a higher
line means higher protection but higher
percentages of that sunscreen ingredient
will give you high protection so the
curve will go up so in terms of the
relative protection it doesn't tell you
that much but it does tell you the
breadth of protection the best uva one
protective ingredients for a long time
where a Vauban zone and zinc oxide ever
been zone or BM DBM gives really good
protection but it's photo unstable which
means it breaks down in UV light so if
it's on your skin it might stop
protecting you for a while unless it's
being stabilized zinc oxide gives you
pretty flat protection throughout the
different wavelengths but the problem is
it has really low protection which means
that in a sunscreen what you need is a
really high percentage to lift that
curve up and the problem with high
percentages is that a lot of the time
the sunscreen feels gross and it gives
you a white cast you can see the white
cast from these three sunscreens that
I've tried in the past
there are now some newest on-screen
ingredients that aren't really that new
but they give better protection and they
avoid these issues with a verb and zone
and zinc oxide they're longer-lasting
because they're photostable
so they don't break down in UV and
they're really effective so you don't
need to have too much in a sunscreen to
give you that high protection
unfortunately most of these aren't
available in the US unless you import a
sunscreen from overseas these are the
best longer-wavelength UVA protective
ingredients there's tuna sub s which is
abbreviated as B EMT tina sub M which is
M B BT mclaurel Excel which is DTS this
is patient at by L'Oreal and it's found
in LA roche-posay products there's also
you vinyl a plus or DHH B max aural SX
or T DSA and there's near Helio pan AP
or DP DT some of the older more
traditional sunscreen ingredients will
also block against UVA too so for
example oxybenzone optic ralien and
titanium dioxide how much protection you
get also depends a lot on the
formulation so make sure you check the
regulator terms as well so the SPF the
PPD the words broad-spectrum as well as
looking for these ingredients if you're
interested in learning more about how to
pick a good sunscreen
I've written a skincare guide which I've
linked below it also talks about how to
pick a good cleanser and a good
moisturizer and how to set up a skincare
routine
as you can probably guess by now
sunscreens aren't the best type of sun
protection a lot of them don't have the
best UVA protection you need to reapply
them regularly and it's really easy to
miss a spot or apply too little but we
do have some other options as well some
protective clothing is a really good
option so things like hats and
sunglasses and shirts hats are really
good for protecting your scalp which is
an area that most of us tend to miss you
should also try to stay in the shade and
avoid sun exposure at peak times UV
that's been reflected off the surface
onto you will still cause damage but a
lot less than the direct UV so you can
see that from the truck-driver photo you
can also look into adding uva tints on
windows that you go near a lot you don't
need to worry too much about the
windshield because they're already
designed to block UVA I hope you like
this video if you did please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to my channel
for more videos you can also follow me
on Instagram for more beauty science and
check out my blog as well see you next
time for more nerdery
you